Mike how are you hello dpi I appreciate
being between Manziel and Dale jr. and
with with the lead in talking about guys
who strike out it's very nice welcome
thank you all right set the scene there
tell tell everybody exactly how this
plays out on Sunday at 5:00 Eastern sure
I said this on the air last night and if
somebody asked me in an interview well
what would be the ideal final pairing on
Sunday and I said right away tiger and
Phil and didn't think about it and this
was on Monday before I even knew they
were going to play a practice round
together yesterday that was kind of a
dozen players I could give you right now
and if we saw any two of those twelve
dueling down the stretch it would be
really fun and that speaks to the depth
of the quality of the field here I know
they usually say in Jack Nicklaus says
this all the time you can eliminate
about half the field maybe 60% of the
field going into masters week but there
are 12 or 13 guys if you see them in the
last group that would be a heck of a
show do I think it'll be Tiger my gut is
no I'm kind of leaning towards Rory and
sometimes you're you're kind of clouded
by time spent with somebody but I just
think his game and his mind is in a
really good place for that and I think
Justin Thomas and Jordan Smith took this
place so well so those if he gave me
those three
I'll take those three and let you take
everybody else when you were talking to
Tiger yesterday and you've been around
Tiger and you mentioned this last night
you know that he he's and he seems to
enjoy it he was surprised at people
following him around for a practice
round and the number of people there
what what have you seen personality-wise
that's different with Tiger blinders are
not as narrow I think he's taking in
more of what's around him and
appreciating health life where he is in
the position he has in golf and I think
part of that Dan was also this task
force that they set up when the US kept
struggling at the Ryder Cup and the
president's couple most of the Ryder Cup
and they
together Jim Furyk and Davis Love and
Tiger and still among the group of guys
to try to figure out how the US could
have a run like the European side had
and through all of that a couple of
things the fill a tiger relationship
group but I think secondly Tiger got to
see firsthand the whole generation of
players who grew up wanting to be like
Tiger and seeing that I think has given
him more of an appreciation for the guys
and I think he's more connected with the
other peers on tour right now than he
was during the best of his days so I see
in general a broader appreciation for
everything around him as he comes back
and plays that's a really respectable
golf with three top 12s and the starts
at Florida leading up to the Masters
there's some masters jargon that's only
masters worthy it's not used at any
other tournament so uh you know can you
fill the listeners and viewers in on
masters jargon yeah patrons I think we
know that
Badgers fans of badgers not tickets
there's the what we refer to on tour or
during the year as grandstands I think
they are patron observations sans patron
observation areas they're forget I
forget Sarah T challenging we say I want
to hear you say that on the air and I'll
say I'll do it right after you do it's
it's it's different but you've been here
you know you you do get caught up in it
it does feel different than every other
place you go for a golf tournament and
when it's hard to get in inside the
gates of the guster national as a player
as a fan as a media member even as a
guest when it's not masters week but
when you get in you get treated better
here than you do anywhere else that you
cover this sport or most any other sport
and that's that's been drive down that
for the last 20 years coming here now
they don't have ruff and Augusta don't
they have the second cut the second card
[Laughter]
you can casually refer to that when
you're out with the Danites playing just
say you know guys give you a roll it
over in the second cut
so you can get a little better a better
lie over there yeah as a matter of fact
you know I'm someplace if we go back to
your mother's hip days yes you were
or didn't you start the Augusta Country
Club run yes yeah yeah that's where I'm
standing right now as a matter of fact
are you playing no no I'm not I'm not
playing we just have the Golf Channel
offices over here we have we do a lot of
our stuff in preparation over here
before going over to the set at Augusta
National but I remember that you were
you were across the way from Augusta
National yeah with this SportsCenter
coverage and then over here but didn't
they take a piece of that golf course
for the 13th tee didn't they pay an
awful lot or what did they give up to
get just a portion of the land behind
13t yeah they have acquired the land
there are so many different wild numbers
or rumors well of what you hear but they
did acquire some land that's right
around the 8th in the ninth hole here at
Augusta Country Club because that
property comes right up to where the
13th tee is and many speculate that
that's how they will lengthen 13 and
that's one of the big concerns here is
will this golf course be able to
continue to grow with guys hitting it so
far so often there you talk to the past
champions here they're really worried
about the ball going too far and are
they hitting the same shots we used to
hit back in the day but it dovetails
right with your home run strikeout
conversation I mean you throw those
numbers out 30 40 years ago yeah people
would say there's no way you're gonna
put somebody in the lineup who strikes
out 200 times a year that's impossible
looks like here you say there's no way
guys gonna hit driver 8-iron 13 well
it's happening and they need to keep
finding ways to make sure that this golf
course stands the test of time they've
done it so far 13 they were kind of land
lot so this property likely in a few
years will lead to a length of the 13
hole and I try to tell people the 13th
hole that that bubble hits it over the
trees like you're not supposed to do
that and and then he has a wedge in on a
par 5 and if you win the par fives at
Augusta chances are you're gonna win
Augusta Andy North you always say when I
work with them during
our ESPN days I decided this point to
her talk about this Andy coined the
phrase tiger par he's a tiger part
Augusta when he was playing great with
68 because he was expected to make a
birdie on all those par fives because of
his life there are now 30 guys in the
field who kind of come to the fives and
think if I don't play them 3-under today
I don't have a chance to keep up with
the rest of the field so how do you how
do you retain the fear factor of instead
of that wedge it's a six it's a four
four I are coming in with the water with
those issues make you think twice about
it the green card can I really do it
then you're back to where this
tournament has been over years and
that's the worry that I think no and
it's fun it's fun for us to watch but by
the same token you want to know that the
players 30 years from now will be
playing a golf course that in some way
resembles the one they played in the
Nicholas II or the Woods Mickelson era
and so on
when's the last time you played Augusta
three years ago I think three years ago
I had a really good really good eight
hole stretch and then reality set in
quickly and well I played terrible as
the other 10 holes I think I shot 88
something like that I'm at 13 handicap
so for me giving it was not the middle
of the golf season for me it was it was
awesome but close I've never had a
hole-in-one the closest I've ever come
in my life was here on the sixth hole
playing with Jay Bilas I hit it to four
inches rushing and then miss the partake
the putter and market and line it up and
knock it in its Augusta I want to want a
real birdie here all right we are going
to we do this every year where we have
to pick we had a three round tournament
where we're picking who we think is
going to win Augusta if you have a
couple of other names other than the
obvious some sleepers there Mike if you
could help us you want me to go off is
Paul Casey in the obvious no all right
I'll give you Paul Casey one one Bay
Hill 13th in the world has been a factor
here on a pretty regular basis
you want somebody really off the radar
yeah
what would you go patting his ire who's
won twice on tour this year do you like
that okay well it felt like for about a
month every time you looked at the you
know FedEx standings cos ire was a top
and we never saw him play in any other
tournament won the you know first two
tournament seriously yeah
how about Alex Noren yeah a chance now
was his inability to close at the Match
Play he ran out of steam playing a lot
of tournaments playing a long week or
getting close to winning in a big spot
the pressure was a little bit too much I
don't know I don't think we know but
Alex Nords 15 in the world right now so
you don't get there and he was higher
than that going into last year's open so
he's been up there that's a not a bad
pick but it's 15 in the world off the
radar yeah but is it not a bad pick mean
that it's kind of a good pick like so
when somebody says hey you're not wrong
does that mean you're right right I
would not pick Alex Noren personally
however if you do I can endorse it as a
season all right hey a great interview
with rory mcilroy last night and and you
pointed out what we realized the last
couple years at Pebble he's honest
you know he wants to give you a good
answer there and I mean he really is he
was great on your show did he well the
problem was he was giving us a putting
lesson and then he even admitted that he
shouldn't be giving us a putting lesson
right he was putting he was honest with
that too and now all of a sudden he's
found some magical form or you know he's
gone back to an old form and he's
putting a lot better he's the winner
this week this week okay maybe there's a
real punishment for Mike Tirico if
shower of shame that you'll get if Rory
does how about this if Rory wins then
we'll go we'll all do a shower of shame
all of us me in the dance yes but if
Rory does it then you have to do a
shower shoe
I can't I can't sign up for that oh
you're too dignified you're right the
brand of Mike Tirico where as a friend
of mine used to say like you softest
church music yeah that's you yeah but
always say that you're softest Church
music is what you're saying thank you
Mike have fun I'll talk to you soon see
you boys will talk you all right Mike
Tirico for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]